quick question aliens come to Earth they
challenge you to a game of chess you
have to save Humanity you have to win
they give you the white pieces what
opening do you play
um in in such a case I'd probably play
an opening like one night that's free or
or the English or some opening that like
that just uh I wouldn't want to stake it
on
um
on Theory battles uh an open battle uh
at first I would probably want to keep a
lot of pieces on the board and try to
um try to to outsmart them eventually uh
besides I mean if I make a couple of
quiet moves at the start I will probably
be able to tell whether the aliens are
any good at chess or or not